Miracle on the Hudson that was kind of a
good opening in a bad period and it
happened 100 seconds after takeoff we
lost thrust in both engines it was a
life-changing event for everyone on the
airplane the NTSB investigation which is
a big part a story that people don't
know until I read the script I didn't
know the investigative board was trying
to paint the picture that he had done
the wrong thing they were kind of
railroading him into as his fault and
that wasn't the case at all there's
something about the near miss like that
it makes you appreciate life as you have
it
cactus 1549 runway 4 clear for takeoff
dad just a minute is detective 1549 lost
thrust on both engines we are turning
back towards the water I have an
emergency he lost both engines returning
immediately today we begin with our
investigation on the crash of US Airways
flight 1549 1549 if we get a few you
want to turn to land runway once right
we're unable we may end up with odd
sensation on crash
this was dual engine loss to them that
were altitude than any jet in history
with 155 souls on
49 left traffic runway 3-1 on it okay
what do you need to land no one has ever
trained for an incident like that
15:49 run my fourth available I don't
think we can make anyone there
what about over to our right off your
right side is Teterboro Airport look I'm
sorry if you're frustrated but our job
is to invest how plane ended up from the
hood still alive you can laugh lovely
wants you tomorrow weekend minute okay
which runway would you like to get a bro
I've delivered a million passengers over
40 years but in the end I'm gonna be
judged on 280 seconds we're gonna end up
in the Hudson I'm sorry say again cactus
this is the captain brace for impact
you